[applause]
ALL RIGHT.
- RIGHT THIS WAY.
COUPLE INTRODUCTIONS
AND WE'LL GET YOU OUT OF HERE.
THIS IS JOHN O'ROURKE.
- NICE TO MEET YOU, JOHN.
- MR. IAN ROBERTS.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- PETER ATENCIO.
- ALL RIGHT, NICE TO MEET YOU.
- JEROME SMITH.
- COME ON, BROTHAH.
WHAT'S UP, FAM?
[chuckling]
YOU KNOW THIS.
- HEATH WILLIAMSON.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- MARY WOODBURY.
- JAY MARTEL.
- NICE TO MEET YOU, SIR.
- TASHA ROBINS.
- COME ON, COME ON, COME ON.
[chuckling]
MMM!
FEEL THAT?
- EMILY GEORGE.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- DARRELL STOKES.
- COME ON.
WHAT'S UP, FAM?
HOW YOU DOIN'?
- ALL RIGHT.
- NEVER FORGET ABOUT THAT,
'CAUSE THAT'S ALL WE GOT.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
NICE TO MEET YOU. ALL RIGHT.
AHH...BRING IT IN,
BRING IT IN!
STARTED FROM THE BOTTOM,
NOW WE HERE.
- YEAH!
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
NICE TO--
- 1/8TH BLACK.
- AFTERNOON, MY OCTOROON.
COME ON, BRING IT IN THERE.
TUCK THAT.
- I'M IN THERE, DOG.
I'M IN THERE, DOG.
- YOU TUCKING IT?
- I'M IN THERE DOG.
- YOU TUCKING IT IN THERE?
- I'M IN THERE.
- LET YOUR TUCK GO.
- I'M IN THERE, DOG.
YOU TUCKING IT?
- MY TUCK.
I'M IN THERE.
- ALL RIGHT.
NICE TO MEET YOU, MAN.
UH, NICE TO MEET YOU.
OH, MY GOODNESS, LOOK AT THIS.
OH, SHE IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
MMM!
I WANT ANOTHER ONE.
THERE YOU GO.
PRECIOUS, BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL.
WHAT'S HER NAME?
- THIS IS LIVIA ROOGEY.
- OKAY.
NICE TO MEET YOU,
MISS ROOGEY.
ALL RIGHT.
COME ON...
THERE HE IS.
BOOM!
- MR. PRESIDENT.
- ALL RIGHT, MAN.
GOOD TO MEET YOU.
- HERE WE GO.
RIGHT THIS WAY, SIR.